who's left to fight I mean that honestly
like I wanted to fight DPP I will fight
about prayer on this I will make this
happen I'll Manifest this it's gonna
rock like rock rob you will do a third
one with Rob I have to if he wins yeah
I'll tell you something after this okay
fair enough yeah I gotta make it
interesting for myself a few moments
later okay breaking news I'm gonna
submit him well Rob wins this fight I'm
gonna submit him I don't care I'm not
gonna knock him out
I'm gonna submit him even though you
could you wanna knock them out for many
times like knockouts
I'm gonna submit you if you want if not
drink us I'm just gonna